[Música]
un abrazo de apoyo en el presidente de
Estados Unidos visitó este lunes por
sorpresa y se reunió con su homólogo de
Mercedes Kia 4 días de que se cumpla el
primer aniversario del inicio de la
invasión rusa a Ucrania biden ya está en
Polonia después de más de 5 horas de
visita en suelo ucraniano donde anunció
un nuevo paquete de 500 millones de
dólares de ayuda
hay un tercer caso en el mundo que ha
conseguido curarse del VIH se lo conoce
como el paciente de dusseldorf y superó
el virus gracias a un trasplante de
células madre para tratar una leucemia
Cómo funcionan estas terapias tenemos
análisis
aumenta a 40 la cifras de muertos por
losas deslaves en el estado de Sao Paulo
en Brasil hay decenas de desaparecidos
mientras cientos de rescatistas buscan
por supervivientes en una tragedia que
enluta las celebraciones del carnaval
momento de actualizar las noticias aquí
en la pantalla de France 24 a ustedes
gracias por continuar con nosotros Yo
soy Juan pupiales
comenzamos con la actualidad de la
guerra en Ucrania la visita Sorpresa del
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden a
kiev el mandatario norteamericano ya
partió de la capital ucraniana y arribó
en las últimas horas a Polonia como ven
en las imágenes y en donde se espera que
entregue un discurso desde Varsovia Este
martes eso se interpreta como un
contrapeso una locución que dará el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin en el
marco del estado de la unión en total
fueron más de cinco horas las que estuvo
biden en el suelo ucraniano a cuatro
días del primer aniversario de la
invasión rusa Irene sabio una de
nuestras enviadas especiales sobre el
terreno tiene más detalles de Esta
visita
una visita sorpresa pero también muy
simbólica y que podría aumentar el tono
del enfrentamiento entre Rusia y
occidente es la que ha hecho hoy Joe
biden aquí a la capital ucraniana el
mandatario estadounidense se ha
desplazado hasta que en una jornada en
la que no han faltado de volver a oírse
las sirenas antiaéreas de hecho las
sirenas han sonado precisamente cuando
el mandatario de Estados Unidos se
encontraba caminando por las calles de
quiebre y en estas circunstancias vayan
a anunciado otro paquete de ayuda por
$470 millones de euros en un momento en
el que los expertos dicen que Rusia se
está preparando para una guerra que aún
durará por mucho tiempo aún así la Casa
Blanca ha informado que comunicó al
remín del desplazamiento de la
mandatario estadounidense a Ucrania con
antelación para evitar mayores tensiones
Mientras tanto la Unión Europea anunció
que prepara una nueva serie de sanciones
contra Rusia el jefe de la política
exterior del bloque comunitario aseguró
que para esta semana estaría aprobado el
que sería el décimo paquete contra el
kremlin y que tendría por objetivo a
medidas contra cuatro bancos así como la
importación y exportación de algunos
productos rusos
on the way it estamos en camino de
aprobarlo y creo que se aprobarán las
próximas horas o en los próximos días
antes en cualquier caso un juego de
tuentiforme
El décimo paquete de sanciones se
aprobará por procedimiento escrito antes
del 24 de febrero los obstáculos que aún
subsisten serán superados Este es el
compromiso de nuestros ministros
dejamos de un lado de la guerra en
Ucrania nuevamente Turquía y Siria
Fueron sacudidas por dos fuertes sismos
que hasta el momento dejan tres
fallecidos y más de 200 heridos Turco de
acuerdo con las cifras oficiales ya son
más de 47.000 las víctimas mortales que
dejan los terremotos del pasado 6 de
febrero la reciente actividad sísmica
pone aún más presión sobre los equipos
de búsqueda y rescate a lo que
recientemente se ha unido la demolición
y reconstrucción de edificios
la tierra volvió a temblar en el sur de
Turquía la provincia de hatay una de las
más afectadas por los devastadores
sismos de hace dos semanas se estremeció
de nuevo con dos terremotos de magnitud
6.4 y 5.8 revivieron el pánico entre la
población
la gente entró en pánico fue un
terremoto muy fuerte había edificios
cerca de las carpas donde estábamos
entonces la gente quedó aislada de sus
familias
nuevos edificios destruidos sobre un
paisaje en ruinas centenares de heridos
y varios muertos en horas de la tarde
durante el temblor muchos se encontraban
en improvisadas tiendas de campaña donde
sobre a temperaturas bajo cero tras
haberlo perdido todo
el mundo empezó a gritar cuando se
produjo el terremoto la gente entró en
pánico y empezó a llorar a gritar y
estaban en estado de shock cuando
bajaron
si seguimos viviendo con este miedo y si
hay más réplicas nos quedaremos en
tiendas de campaña buscaremos Refugio
hasta que la situación se calme
según las autoridades turcas para la
gestión de desastres se han registrado
más de 6.200 réplicas en los últimos 15
días y afirman que se seguirán sintiendo
Durante un año debido a la fuerza del
primer temblor
iba a pasar era predecible lo estábamos
esperando ahora esperamos más todo el
mundo debería estar más preparado para
esto
los peores terremotos en décadas dejan
ya más de 47,000 Muertos en el sur de
Turquía y el noroeste de Siria y miles
más sin hogar mientras continúan
buscando supervivientes y las
autoridades locales inician las labores
de reconstrucción este lunes el estado
estadounidense Anthony blinken prometió
desde ankara la ayuda humanitaria por el
tiempo que sea necesario
en otros temas el consejo de seguridad
de Naciones Unidas expresó su
preocupación por los planes del gobierno
de Israel liderado por el Primer
Ministro Benjamín que van encaminados a
legalizar la construcción y expansión de
los asentamientos de ciudadanos
israelíes en tierras palestinas la
representante permanente de Malta ante
la organización de Naciones Unidas que
presidió la sesión dijo que esta
actividad solo empeora el conflicto
entre israelíes y palestinos por su
parte el Premier israelí afirmó que
dicha declaración niega el derecho
histórico afirmó a los judíos sobre el
territorio en el que se encuentran
el Consejo de Seguridad reitera que las
continuas actividades de asentamientos
israelíes están poniendo en peligro
peligrosamente la viabilidad de una
solución de dos estados basada en las
líneas de 1967
el Consejo de Seguridad subraya
enérgicamente la necesidad de que todas
las partes cumplan con sus obligaciones
y compromisos internacionales se opone
enérgicamente a todas las medidas
unilaterales que impidan la paz
incluidas entre otras la construcción y
expansión israelí de asentamientos la
confiscación de territorios palestinos
en tierra y la legalización ante los
asentamientos la demolición de viviendas
palestinas y el desplazamiento de
civiles palestinos
una esperanzadora noticia fue publicada
por la revista especializada en nature
hablamos de un estudio sobre el tercer
paciente curado del VIH del VIH el
conocido como paciente deducedorf una
ciudad alemana es un individuo cuya
identidad se mantiene en secreto y que
logró erradicar cualquier rastro del
virus después de un trasplante de
células madre para tratar una leucemia
conectamos en este momento con el doctor
Erick Delgado
Zárate magíster en enfermedades
infecciosas y VIH especialista en
epidemiología y salud pública señor
Zárate cómo funciona primero que todo
gracias por estar con nosotros y cómo
funciona este tipo de tratamientos Y qué
posibles que esas terapias se hagan a
gran escala
Bueno pues
Este ha sido aplicadas
es que tienen
leucemia Y en este caso un paciente con
linfoma realmente son pacientes que
tienen enfermedades
asociadas al VIH donde lo que se busca
es a través de El trasplante de médula
ósea poder generar la capacidad de que
en un momento dado
se genere la presencia de mutaciones en
el momento en que se hace la donación de
la médula y con esto lograr la prevenir
la replicación del virus del VIH sin
embargo es muy importante explicar que
este tipo de terapias no se pueden
llevar a gran escala son terapias
altamente costosas Pero además de eso
requieren de muchos estudios y además de
eso no todos los pacientes son
candidatos a a este tipo de terapias
Generalmente lo que hemos visto con el
primer paciente que es lo conocemos como
el paciente Berlín El segundo paciente
que lo conocemos como el paciente
Londres es que se ha logrado la
implementación o el el lograr una
mutación que lleva finalmente a que los
pacientes finalmente presenten este tipo
de cura pero no es una terapia aplicable
a toda la población o a más de los 37
millones de personas que habitan en el
planeta después de en ese momento con
diagnóstico de VIH no sabe usted de que
son terapias caras que no todo el mundo
las puede recibir profundizando en ese
tema Qué riesgos tienen este tipo de
trasplantes
bueno
fue trasplantes tenemos expuestos a las
personas que se someten a ellos
principalmente a enfermedades
infecciosas a complicaciones de tipo
infeccioso que pueden llevar a al a la
muerte de los pacientes y además de esto
que no se garantiza 100% ya que esto
requiere una serie de seguimientos al
cabo de dos o tres años en la revista
hace la publicación el día de hoy pero
realmente este paciente lleva con un
seguimiento de más de cuatro años en el
cual se ha logrado determinar que
efectivamente no hay trazas del virus o
las pocas trazas que hay en este momento
en su organismo no tienen una
replicación activa frente a la
enfermedad
Muchísimas gracias doctor Zárate por
haber estado con nosotros con este
análisis aquí en France 24 sobre este
caso del Tercer paciente curado del VIH
Muchas gracias
importante transmitirle a todos los
pacientes de VIH que debe mantener el el
acceso a la terapia antirretroviral que
esto es lo que en este momento nos está
llevando no solamente a la
indetectabilidad sino al impacto la
morbilidad y enfermedad Gracias era el
doctor
Zárate vamos a cambiar de tema noticias
de América Latina las autoridades del
estado de Sao Paulo en Brasil reportan
al menos 40 muertos y más de 300
damnificados tras un fin de semana de
lluvias en récord el gobierno Estatal
decretó la calamidad pública y anunció
la liberación de 1,3 millones de dólares
de ayudas para las tareas de rescate
Mientras tanto el presidente Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva visitó la región y
prometió paliar los daños
Caos y destrucción tras una fuerte
jornada de lluvias récord que afectó el
norte del estado de Sao Paulo en Brasil
en especial en la ciudad de Sao
Sebastián durante el fin de semana de
carnaval provocando inundaciones y
deslizamientos de tierra el gobierno de
Sao Paulo decretó el estado de calamidad
pública por 180 días en las cinco
ciudades más afectadas y el presidente
Lula da Silva prometió una acción o
coordinada
puedo garantizar que mis ministros y el
gobernador están dispuestos a dialogar
para que podamos trabajar conjuntamente
para reparar de manera efectiva los
daños que la lluvia ha ocasionado aquí
en Sao Sebastián
las lluvias acumularon unos 600
milímetros superando el nivel que se
esperaba para todo el mes de febrero en
medio del carnaval además de los cientos
de personas que se vieron obligadas a
evacuar sus hogares muchos viajeros que
decidieron pasar sus vacaciones en la
región también tuvieron que evacuar
desastre por el que el gobierno como
local haya anunciado el desembolso de
alrededor de un millón y medio de
dólares para las tareas de rescate y
reconstrucción
ayer no pudimos sacar nuestro auto Así
que está dañado y casi perdemos otras
cosas de dentro de casa
la situación está crítica sólo tenemos
una salida para ir hacia Sao Paulo está
todo inundado
estamos medio aislados aquí con ráfagas
de viento que marcaron hasta 55
kilómetros por hora el Instituto
Nacional de meteorología reportó que las
lluvias continuaran en la zona costera
del estado en los próximos días Lo que
podría agravar la situación
precisamente esa tragedia en Sao Paulo
en lute las tradicionales celebraciones
del carnaval en Río de Janeiro es el
lunes se vive la última jornada de
desfiles antes de que se decida qué
escuela de samba es la ganadora
previamente nuestra corresponsal en Río
valerezacona nos envió el siguiente
informe
mera paraíso de Toyota mi espalda para
una competición que está llena de reglas
porque cada escuela puede tener de 2500
a 3.200 miembros además la batería la
orquesta puede tener mínimo 200 músicos
tiene que haber alas de mínimo 100
personas y todo tiene que estar en su
lugar recordamos que los últimos años
muchas escuelas padecen de gigantismos
hacer carros alegóricos enormes que lo
consiguen pasar la culpa y entrar en
esta Avenida que mide 700 metros Y
entonces se crean espacios entre las
alas que hacen perder
estamos oyendo los juegos artificiales
que marcan el inicio el primer desfile
noche de fiesta el miércoles tendremos
el resultado de una fiesta que no solo
genera alegría para el pueblo sino
también mucho dinero 87
millones de dólares de facturación según
los datos oficiales del ayuntamiento de
Río de Janeiro
más imposible que iba imposible ese
ambiente de valeriaconas y terminamos
este informativo aquí en la pantalla de
24 ustedes quédense con nuestra señal y
también visiten nuestro sitio web France
24.com
[Música]